[Music]
Penda Skinner
I'll just keep this open right here you
never know when when I'll show up you
know that's what's great about Pokemon
I've been playing Pokemon No
do you know all the ones to look for wow
there is it yeah I know I know the ones
that I don't have but their regional so
you'll get different ones here than you
would get in New York or Europe or Asia
so you read there was that guy that got
them all there was a guy that just spent
all of his time traveling I think around
the room and he only got the ones the
United States where to get all the ones
in the world that's impossible I don't
know and then I would imagine that point
the company was like who has captured
who and then I'll just wrap them in a
ball yeah I don't know though I mean I'm
level 18 right now which I don't you
know you know means nothing to me
yeah yeah I don't know what you're
talking about he mister T mister
[Applause]
well
now you you say that you like Pokemon
because it it's a game that keeps you
physically active as opposed to we all
know this sort of the cliche of the
gamer who's like sitting on his couch
vacant eyes not moving yes yes you think
it's beautiful yeah first of all that's
what I tell my mom and my fiance I'm
like it's for fitness but me out of the
house I mean it practically in a gym
right I know I am practically at a gym
we're gonna take it over to music but
but yes gaming is very isolating because
your home you'll spend four or five
hours I play RPGs and those are you know
you can play 40 50 60 70 hours of that
and so with this it really does it kind
of makes the Nerds kind of wipe the
crust out of their eyes and go out and
talk to other people and have community
makes them walk in front of a bus no you
still aren't people falling off cliffs
left and right well no I don't think
there is a Gore Bull
[Applause]
thing is you can't blame the app for
that guys you still have to live like a
responsible human beings people some of
them haven't gone outside ever right so
they just so they don't know about cars
yeah
they don't know they're like ah like
this can sky on fire like oh my god land
whale bone oh so this was happening all
at comic-con yeah now tell us about that
cuz you moderated a bunch of you might
have read it like 10 panel I did yeah at
comic-con yeah and you moderated a
pokeymon panel I did what happens at a
pokeymon panel well you can't even look
at me right shut up you're on television
on a show and you keep looking down to
see if gurgle Plex is if we were at
dinner and a restaurant my wife would
make it would take that away from know
yeah well the great thing about Pokemon
it is it put me in the unique situation
where I had to apologize to two women in
a yogurt shop that I was not
photographing their children so I
learned the Turing creatures I promise
all evolve give them candy now I'm doing
it now I'm not even paying it so yeah we
did a panel with John Hanke who who is
the founder of Niantic who runs this and
they had no idea that I mean they knew
people were probably gonna be into it
but they didn't know how explosive it
would be because when they planned the
panel was probably two months ago yeah
and then the thing blew up in the last
couple of weeks yeah to this the same
degree where most people in the world
right now are not making eye contact
with each other they're playing this
game I don't know what you're talking
about Conan O'Brien son of a [ __ ]
I know please don't do that he was
oriented the right way I will snap that
finger so they thought they were gonna
be in a small Hall and then all a small
room and then all the sudden it blew up
and so they went into Hall H which you
were moderating stuff there it's that
big it is the big big 5,000 people yeah
life success it has its own climate it's
great its own weather pattern right no
one is showered in a year no no it
doesn't matter ever it's it's all own
society people you know they clean each
other recycle all the ways but we so
people were there and I think they were
expecting some sort of a an announcement
oh there's gonna be a legendary Pokemon
which Niantic never said so people kind
of were a little thrown off but for this
company so you had like 6,000 you had a
lot of people show up to a convention
thinking we're gonna see a new creature
in the room right it's the Pokemon room
and they didn't have a creature right
they didn't have a creature I think
didn't they try to just panic at the
last second I'm sure like a red pillow
out there
you